I think a lot of people right now are
upset with the state of our economy
economic freedom is something that
everyone's really receptive to hi I'm
Tim Cavanaugh a reason TV we're here
with Michelle fields is the campus
coordinator for students for liberty in
the LA area Michelle thanks for coming
and joining us thank you tell us a
little bit about students for liberty
yeah students for liberty is a
non-profit run by students for students
so we distribute resources to pro
Liberty student groups on campuses
throughout the entire country and we
provide resources for them to have
conferences and have speakers come what
would be something other than condoms
that students would be interested in
getting as their hand out what do you
guys give away we give away a lot of pro
Liberty books and just resources and
literature for them to learn more about
these ideas you mentioned that you're at
Pepperdine and you are the campus
coordinator for the entire LA area so
that means there's nobody at UCLA nobody
USC nobody at Occidental the president's
alma mater what's the hold up there I
mean if you guys are for sex drugs and
rock and roll wire students not more
active in this I think it's really about
reaching the students and exposing them
to these ideas that are just not exposed
to it on stone campuses and professors
don't talk about the ideas of Liberty do
you get more response from Democrats or
Republicans to put it crudely usually
Republicans they're more receptive
towards the ideas of Liberty because
they are fiscally conservative it's just
getting them on those social issues and
foreign policy what are the big social
issues that you kids are you know still
sticking on these days and it seems like
gay marriage is kind of a battle that's
been one in the next generations hearts
of minds but tell me what sir well
actually gay marriage is one of the
biggest issues when I'm talking to
conservatives of trying to get them to
be more receptive to pro Liberty ideas
they're not for gay marriage so it's
really sort of a struggle still any
other stuff i mean drug war stuff you
still find republicans are kind of
stenting at a libertarian taking the
full dive yeah they're being a little
more receptive towards legalization of
marijuana but that's as far as
they go even if they consider I mean
they usually are are not as receptive as
libertarians towards legalization of
drugs what's the biggest sell what the
libertarians have right now that
everybody says I like that I think a lot
of people right now are upset with the
state of our economy so economic freedom
is something that everyone's really
receptive to how about not social but
sort of taste issues certainly it reason
we tend to be a bunch of you know
middle-aged former punk rockers so what
are you talking about in terms of like
culturally where do you think's
libertarian oriented students are these
days and are they all Glee fans or
what's the thing um no I don't think
they're Glee fans I find that a lot of
them are just really about you know
reading literature online and most of
the people that I find that our
libertarians are really intellectually
curious so they don't spend that much
time watching TV shows and movies it's
about watching documentaries and
continuing to learn more about crow
liberty ideas
you